american allies slapping more crushing
sanctions on russia aimed at crippling
vladimir putin and his economy the
latest target is the country's central
bank and limiting its ability to make
financial transactions russia's currency
the ruble has hit an all-time low and
its stock market is closed today after
crashing
europe also very united the eu is
shutting down its airspace to russian
planes and is also sending ukraine
military aid so harold
is it possible that what vladimir putin
is leading his country into is a north
korean future where you're kind of i
mean he's got no friends to play with
anymore he likes to travel he can't
travel there's no sports team you know
they i mean there's no world cup this is
literally what if you want to be the
next north korea he just chose that path
one thing the russian people are going
to probably have to decide in the near
term not the oligarchs but the people
actually live in russia is how they want
to live uh do you want to pay two times
three times four times for things that
you've already bought or things that you
want to buy because the ruble is losing
value and because your your central bank
can't borrow enough
on the open markets um do you want a
country where your energy uh is crippled
because you can't sell any and you can't
turn on anything
uh for the first time a generation of
europeans are understanding what it's
like to live like their parents and
grandparents and great-grandparents once
told them that europe was so i know i
think at the end of the day if if trump
i mean i'm sorry if if if if putin wants
ukraine or any nation in the eastern
bloc to want to be like russia then have
them have do something that makes them
want to be like russia not go in and
invade them and took a hammer over their
head our ideas are winning and i think
that bothers him more than anything and
what he's done could actually make her
ideas more win more amongst the russian
people than anything we could have done
by attacking or spending more money this
may be a great boon for the ideas that
independence and democracy are built on
yeah the only thing i had to push back
hashtags aren't the same as bombs you
know
like that we do we we do fall in love
with the spirit of this thing but they
got the bombs and we were talking about
in the break
russians got they got a ton of stuff
they aren't using yet yeah i haven't
seen a lot of the russian air force when
that comes in it's going to be a
different landscape down there uh but
i'm happy to see the europeans wake up
over the weekend it looks like because
russia hadn't advanced as rapidly as
expected on the capitol and they were on
the phone with zielinski who said yeah
you know you might not hear from me
again that kind of made him face reality
so these are tough sanctions
the swift sanctions are strong there is
a little carve out for energy
transactions of course yes and
when the
germans
decided to send weaponry and double
their defense spending in two years i i
was excited and then i remembered what
happens when the germans ramp up
military
so that gives people some flashbacks so
hopefully that can be balanced out there
the
attacks against the oligarchs who knows
if that's even going to work they're
targeting their private jets that seems
to be good and they're not going to let
commercial aircraft fly over there so i
guess people are going to be eating at
home for a while the attacks against the
central bank seem to be the most
devastating if you're holding russian
government debt right now that's like a
junk bond that's done worse that's worse
than jump on that's goodbye so i don't
know what they're going to do with that
but that's pretty strong
the food problem is could be serious
because the last time they couldn't
export wheat i think they had the arab
spring because that's who purchases all
the russian and ukrainian wheat there
was a famine and everybody went wild so
that's also something to look out for if
they respond to this all these crippling
sanctions with cyber
or i heard they could even cut our
underwater cables
that deal with our internet that could
get really crazy hopefully it doesn't
escalate to that
even katie even switzerland i know
sanctioned russia and that i mean they
have oligarchs have 11 billion
dollars i guess dollars not rubles i
think it's 11 billion let's let's talk
about this 11 billion pounds yes
something like that yeah maybe gold bars
i mean everything's connected they're
gonna have to get rid of putin if they
want their money back you know that
they've they've screwed up and that
there's been an awakening when
switzerland and sweden are getting
involved especially switzerland with the
banking and the sanctions on not wanting
to make money off of what's going on
it's been interesting to look at this
from the perspective of for years russia
has been used as a political point right
ukraine has been used as corrupt
playground for elites to go get rich
hunter and joe biden included and now
it's all kind of coming home to roost
when it comes to what's actually
happening here and europe does seem to
be waking up you have germany saying of
course the two percent they're paying
more but it's interesting to look at the
map as well and who's been paying more
all along because they took the russia
threat seriously
from the beginning poland always pays
two percent croatia latvia estonia
romania and now you have western
european countries waking up and going
oh okay this is actually a real thing
that we're going to have to deal with
and so you've seen europe come together
and now you're seeing finland wanting to
join nato so you've seen this effort by
putin to limit nato actually expanding
including zielinski today signing that
that request to join the european union
so we'll see where it goes but it
certainly has created unity among the
europeans which i we have not seen in a
very long time do you think uh judge
that putin even
i mean
he's he acts irrational but there's an
irrational part to him that he saw this
coming and
he's wet he's ready to endure this like
the berry is you know we'll talk about
that a little later in the show but one
of the ironies that i can talk about now
i want to talk about one of the ironies
one of the uh we will in the next in the
next block and i'll ask you the question
but one of the ironies here is because
putin didn't go in and succeed as
quickly as he did
he gave the west the opportunity to
coalesce and even as you say to get
switzerland finland everyone in the west
is involved and so his hesitation or his
effort whether it is because he's
holding back as some of us at the table
feel or you know because he thought he'd
save the infrastructure it is to our
benefit and to his detriment and now
with these financial uh uh sanctions the
guy is in real trouble in trouble with
his own people in trouble with
ukrainians who were have family in
russia i mean i i'm not so sure the
guy's got his game on right now but for
him to jump to
let's get a nuclear uh alert status
let's let's jump to that um that's in
the next uh segment on the next block
but i thought i'd just tweak oh you're
you're calling the keys
thank you very much all right
up next as russia threatens nuclear war
new concerns vladimir putin is mentally
unhinged